sources tell CBS News CIA director Gina  Haspel has briefed President Trump on  what she learned from Turkey about the  murder of Washington Post contributor  Jamal Khashoggi hospital is into an  audio recording that allegedly captured  Khashoggi 'he's killing inside the Saudi  consulate in Istanbul Saudi officials  now call it now call his death  premeditated after originally denying he  was captured inside the consulate more  than three weeks ago Ashoka's body still  has not been found a sorts source tells  CBS News Khashoggi son has been allowed  to leave Saudi Arabia for the US after  the Saudi King and Crown Prince met with  him this week to pay their respects